all right back here at home john 607 on
your tuesday morning want to check the
economy in north las vegas there's a new
program to fire up small businesses an
arby alcoholman live at the north las
vegas city hall with the details i bet
you're getting some people's attention
like how do i get involved
yes send out the word send out the all
call text somebody right now who's an
entrepreneur and tell them to watch
right now the small business connector
center is located here at city hall in
north las vegas and i'm told that small
businesses are really the backbone of
north las vegas so we were there when
they opened up the office in october and
of course they have helped so many
businesses since then they've been busy
the north las vegas
connector is funded by the american
rescue plan act it's a part of the
city's coven 19 response efforts from
general tech issues starting a business
or even expansion of your new business
so many people have changed careers
leaving jobs to start their own business
so this program is making a huge impact
we've heard from a business who has
participated in our revolving loan fund
that said that they kind of fell victim
to some predatory practices because it
was the only way for them to access the
capital they needed to grow their
business and now our fund is actually
give them an opportunity to get out from
under that
and give them a path forward so that's
really really important
so here are some numbers this is what
they've been up to in the past three
months they've helped over 100
businesses three started from scratch
and the program has loaned three hundred
fifty thousand dollars they've got more
to give until they reach the ultimate
amount of two million dollars so yes if
you live in north las vegas you can and
your business is based in north las
vegas you can qualify for funding some
cold hard cash that can definitely go a
long way now coming up in the next half
hour we're going to share some more
details on the program and how you know
if you can qualify reporting live in
north las vegas bianca holman live local
now